In this lecture, we continue discussing
paradigmatic relation discovery.
Earlier, we introduced a method called
expected overlap of words in context.
In this method, we represent each
context by a word vector that represents
the probability of word
in the context and we measure the
similarity by using the DOT product.
Which can be interpreted as the
probability that to randomly pick the
words from the two contexts
are identical, we also discuss the two
problems of this method.
The first is that it favors matching
one frequent term very well over
matching more distinct terms.
It put too much emphasis on matching
one term very well.
The second is that it treats every word
equally.
Even a common word like 'the' would
contribute equally as content word like
'eats'.
So now we are going to talk about how
to solve these problems.
Most specifically, we're going to
introduce some retrieval heuristics
used in text retrieval, and these
heuristics can effectively solve these
problems, as these problems also occur
in text retrieval when we match a query
vector with document vector.
So to address the first problem, we can
use a sub linear transformation of term
frequency.
That is, we don't have to use the raw
frequency count of term to represent
the context.
We can transform it into some form that
wouldn't emphasize so much on the raw
frequency. To address the second
problem, we can put more weight on rare
terms.
That is, we can reward matching a
rare word and this heuristic is called
IDF term weighting in text retrieval.
IDF stands for inverse document
frequency.
So now we're going to talk about the
two heuristics in more detail.
First, let's talk about the TF
transformation.
That is, to convert the raw count of
word in the document into some weight
that reflects our belief about how
important this word in the document.
And so that will be denoted by TF of
W&D as shown in the Y axis.
Now in general there are many ways to
map that, and let's first look at the
simple way of mapping.
In this case, we're going to say, any
non zero counts will be mapped to one.
And then zero count will be mapped to
0.
So with this mapping, all the
frequencies will be mapped to only two
values, zero or one, and the mapping
function is shown here as a flat line
here.
Now this is naive because it
ignored the frequency of words.
However, this actually has the
advantage of emphasizing matching all
the words in the context, so it does
not allow a frequent word to dominate
the matching.
Now the approach that we have taken
earlier in the expected overlap account
approach is a linear transformation.
We basically take Y as the same as X.
So we use the raw count as
representation.
And that created the problem that we
just talked about.
Namely it answers too much on just
matching one frequent term. Matching one
frequent term can contribute a lot.
So we can have a lot of other
interesting transformations in between
the two extremes.
And they generally form a sub linear
transformation.
So for example, one possibility is to
take logarithm of the raw count, and
this will give us curve that looks like
this, right?
That you're seeing here.
In this case, you can see the high
frequency counts,
the high counts are penalized a little
bit right?
So the curve is a sub linear curve, an
it brings down the weight of
really those really high counts.
And this is what we want, because it
prevents that kind of terms from
dominating the scoring function.
Now there is also another interesting
transformation called a BM25
transformation which has been shown to
be very effective for retrieval and in
this transformation we have a form
that.
Looks like this.
I saw it's (K + 1) * X /( X + K) where K is
a parameter.
X is the count, the raw count of word.
Now the transformation is very
interesting in that it can actually
kind of go from one extreme to the
other extreme by varying K.
And it also is interesting that it has
upper bound
K +1 in this case.
So this puts a very strict constraint
on high frequency terms, because their
weight would never exceed K+1.
As we vary K,
if we can simulate the two extremes.
So one case is set to zero.
We roughly have the 01 vector.
Whereas when we set the key to a very
large value, it would behave more like
the linear transformation.
So this transformation function is by
far the most effective transformation
function for text retrieval, and it
also makes sense for our problem set
up.
So we just talk about how to solve the
problem of over emphasizing a
frequently frequent term.
Now let's look at the second problem,
and that is how we can penalize popular
terms.
Matching 'the' is not surprising because
'the' occurs everywhere, but matching
'eats' will account a lot.
So how can we address that problem?
In this case we can use the
IDF weighting that's commonly used in
retrieval. IDF stands for inverse
document frequency.
Document frequency means the count
of the total number of documents that
contain a particular word.
So here we show that the IDF
measure is defined as a logarithm
function of the number of documents
that match the term,
or document frequency.
So K is the number of documents
containing word or document frequency
and M
here is the total number of documents
in the collection.
The IDF function is giving a higher
value for a lower K, meaning that it
rewards a rare term.
And the maximum value is log of M + 1.
That's when the word occurs just once
in the context.
So that's a very rare term,
the rarest term in the whole
collection.
The lowest value you can see here is
when K reaches its maximum, which would
be M.
That would be a very low value
close to 0 in fact.
Right so this.
This of course measure is used in
search where we naturally have a
collection.
In our case, what will be our
collection?
We can also use the context that we can
collect for all the words as our
collection and that is to say, a word
that's popular in the collection in
general
would also have a low IDF.
Because depending on the data set, we
can
construct the context vectors in
different ways, but in the end, if a
term is very frequently in the original
data set, then it would still be
frequently in the collected context
documents.
So how can we add these heuristics to
improve our.....
Our similarity function.
Here's one way, and there are many
other ways that are possible.
But this is a reasonable way where we
can adapt the BM25 retrieval model for
paradigmatic relation mining.
So here
we define in this case we define the
document vector.
As containing elements
representing normalized BM 25 values.
So in this normalization function we
see we take sum over some of all the
words and then we
normalize the weight of each word by
the sum of the weights of
all the words.
This is to again ensure all the
x(i) will sum to one in this
vector.
So this would be very similar to what
we had before in that this vector is
actually something similar to word
distribution or the exercise with sum
to one.
Now the weight of BM25 for each word is
defined here.
And if you compare this with our old
definition where we just have a
normalized count.
On this one, right?
So we only have this one and the
document length or the total count of
words in that context document.
And that's what we had before.
But now with the BM 25 transformation,
we introduced something else.
First, of course, this extra occurrence
of this count is just to achieve the
sub linear normalization.
But we also see we introduce the
parameter K here.
And this parameter is generally non
negetive number, although zero is also
possible.
This controls the upper bound and
the kinds controls can choose
To what extent is simulates the linear
transformation.
And so this is 1 parameter.
But we also see there is another
parameter here b and this will be
within zero and one.
And this is a parameter to control  length
normalization.
And, and in this case the normalizing
formula has average document length
here.
And this is the computed by taking the
average of the lengths of all the
documents in the collection.
In this case, all the lengths of all the
context documents that we are
considering.
So this average documents will be a
constant for any given collection, so
it actually is only affecting the
effect of the parameter B here.
Because this is a constant.
But I kept it here because it's
constant that's useful in retrieval,
where it would give us a stabilized
interpretation of parameter b.
But for our purpose this will be a
constant, so it would only be
affecting the length formalization
together with parameter B.
Now with this definition, then we have
a new way to define our document
vectors and we can compute the vector
D2 in the same way.
The difference is that the high
frequency terms will now have a
somewhat lower weights and this would
help control the influence of these
high frequency terms.
Now the IDF can be added here in
the scoring function.
That means we'll introduce weight for
matching each term. So you may recall
this sum indicates all the possible
words that can be a overlap between the
two contexts.
And the Xi and Yi probabilities of
picking the word from both contexts,
therefore it indicates how likely will
see a match on this word.
Now IDF would give us the importance
of matching this word.
A common word will be worth less than
rare word, so we emphasize more on
matching rare words now.
So with this modification, then the new
function will likely address those two
problems.
Now interestingly
we can also use this approach to
discover syntagmatic relations.
In general, when we represent a
term vector to represent the sorry to
represent context with the term vector, we
would likely see some terms have
higher weights and other terms have lower
weights depending on how we assign
weights to these terms, we might be
able to use these weights to discover
the words that are strongly associated
with the candidate word in the
context.
So let's take a look at the term vector
in more detail here.
And we have each
Xi, defined as a normalized weight of
BM 25.
Now this weight alone only reflects how
frequently the word occurs in the
context.
But we can't just say any
frequent term in the context that would
be correlated with the candidate word.
Because many common words like 'the' will
occur frequently in all the context.
But if we apply IDF weighting as you
see here, we can then
we weight these terms based on IDF
That means the words that are common,
like 'the' will get penalized.
So now the highest weighted terms will
not be those common terms because they
have lower IDFs.
Instead, those terms would be the terms
that are frequent in the context, but
not frequently in the collection.
So those are clearly the words that
tend to occur in the context of the
candidate word, for example, cat.
So for this reason, the highly weighted
terms in this IDF weighted vector
can also be assumed to be candidate for
Syntagmatic relations.
Now of course, this is only a bi-product
of our approach for discovering
paradigmatic relations.
And in the next lecture, we're going to
talk more about how to discover
Syntagmatic relations.
But it clearly shows the relation
between discovering the two relations.
And indeed they can be discussed,
discovered in a joint manner by
leveraging such associations.
So to summarize,
the main idea for discovering
paradigmatic relations is to collect the
context of a candidate word to form a
pseudo document, and this is typically
represented as a bag of words.
And then compute the similarity of the
corresponding context documents of two
candidate words.
An then we can take the highly similar
word pairs and treat them as having
paradigmatic relations.
These are the words that share similar
context.
And there are many different ways to
implement this general idea and we just
talk about some of the approaches.
And more specifically, we talked about
using text retrieval models to help us
design effective similarity function to
compute the paradigmatic
relations.
More specifically, we have used the
BM25 and IDF weighting to
discover paradigmatic relation and
these approaches also represent the
state of the art in text retrieval
techniques.
Finally, Syntagmatic relations can also
be discovered as a bi-product
when we discover paradigmatic
relations.